fox news alert for you now uh nearly 2
000 modern vaccines were compromised
out of boston facilities terrible news
the va boston pharmacy says
the freezer failed because the plug was
loose
okay so we'll keep an eye on that
joining us now is dr mark siegel he's
fox news contributor
and professor of medicine at nyu langone
dr siegel these
vaccines are precious um and some of
them are just sitting on shelves
in states across the country
well dana actually you started right
where i want to start which is i don't
think anybody's talked about the idea of
how difficult it is to make these
vaccines
they are precious they are fragile and
they're made with a technology that's
never been used before
the lysosome to use a fancy word is the
coat the fat coat around the messenger
rna
that's very hard to do so united states
contracted for 100 million and then a
second hundred million doses of pfizer
100 million and a second hundred million
with moderna that's 400 million doses
but it doesn't mean that the
manufacturers can deliver that
as asked as as needed so there's a delay
there in terms of the manufacturing side
and then as you pointed out once it's
transported once it gets to
the freezers sometimes they're
compromised as well
um doc what do you think about what the
white house is saying about
starting from scratch what what what do
you think of the vaccination number you
know 100 million in the first hundred
days
seems like we're on track for that my
information says we've reached a rate
of roughly nine hundred thousand a day
is that shots is that people what is
that doc
that's that's shots bill that's not
people so that's again that's half of
what we ultimately want we want we would
want to be able to
fully vaccinate i mean we vaccinated now
about 17 and a half million people but
only about 3 million have gotten second
doses and i feel the science
really supports the second dose but to
your initial question
there's absolutely no way that the
administration should be talking about
about it this way the new administration
there was a vaccine plan in place we
went over it meticulously on this show
there's a lot of moving parts here
they're not starting from scratch
they're picking up the ball where it was
and they're moving it forward i think
national vaccination centers make sense
i think getting a lot more into
pharmacies makes sense
because that's where people get their
vaccines generally doctors offices or
pharmacies
but a lot of this is already moving
forward and we're on a rate as you just
said
to do 100 million doses over the next
100 days
absolutely we're already on that track
but we're getting a shortage now
dr siegel i wanted to ask you about this
i saw this headline today it caught my
eye on the ap
that a lucky few are hitting the covid
19 vaccine
jackpot for rare extra doses i mean
that's how
much people want to be vaccinated
sometimes you show up at one o'clock in
the morning at some of these places
turns out there's no one else in line
you might not be in a certain criteria
but they've got these doses they don't
want to waste them
so you could be your lucky day like
winning the mega millions jackpot
well dana i actually really like that
but but i would add to that i'd like to
see a plan b in a plan c in other words
it's disturbing to think a 38 million
doses have been sent around
but only 17 and a half million have been
given i want each vaccine center to say
look
we want to target health care workers
first and those over 65
but but as the report just before me
said look what about people with
diabetes what about people with
other pre-existing conditions they
should be on the near the top of the
list
and we do know who has those medical
problems we know exactly who has those
medical problems
so i don't want it to have to be like
vegas where oh here's a shot and
everybody runs for it
i'd rather that it's very systematically
set up get a handle on it indeed
thank you doc i know two people getting
a vaccination today three you know three
oh oh
well bill and george ann hammer and jan
jan
amazing on the same day how are you here
bill 73
love that age 81 here we go thank you
doc nice to see you mark segal thanks